il nous revient sur scène mais au fait
l'at il jamais vraiment quitté manu
dibango le pionnier de la musique
africaine en france est avec nous ce
soir un artiste qui va donner des
couleurs dans quelques jours au festival
chorus des hauts-de-seine vous jouerez
avec le zaïrois ray lema et défendre et
ainsi aller sont du continent africain
une musique de plus en plus tendance
petit aperçu en répétition avec
jean-françois chevet
cette année manu dibango le camerounais
et ray lema le zaïrois ont décidé d'unir
leurs talents
à 65 ans après une carrière bien remplie
jalonnée de tubes manu dibango n'a pas
l'intention de prendre sa retraite
oh
ce monsieur a une joie du jouet qui
jusqu'aujourd'hui est intacte moi je
pense que c'est ça qui fait sa force
c'est pour ça qu'il est toujours là
quand il joue hélas toujours cette
lumière d'enfants dans ses yeux et c'est
merveilleux ces deux musiciens sont les
pionniers d'un courant musical africain
inspiré par le jazz 1 sont repris dans
le monde entier d'abord une fois puis
ensemble pendant que tu as entendu jouer
moi je sais pas quel membre a fait part
balade
est toujours sourire très sonore de
vreni dit nous avons soir la joie de
jouer elle est toujours là et en
évidence un coq ce contrat vie jusqu'au
bout un 6ème quoi on l'a naturellement
en fait c'est pas on s'apprête pas je
crois qu'on aime ça est un shônen sans
cali pas évidemment elle vous vient d'où
cette joie de jouer est ce qu'elle est
et des halles à petit ouais j'ai
toujours aimé ça et je sors d'une
famille qui est qui qui s'apprêtait pas
ça parce que votre et protestantes tout
ça très dur mais par contre à l'église
mam a dirigé la chorale d'un autre côté
mon oncle paternel comme on était un peu
al marrant il était instituteur du tas d
alma usuels les l'harmonium donc j'ai eu
des deux côtés un peu dit sont à la
maison c'était du sang alléluia moi j'en
ai fait autre chose et vous en avez fait
quoi justement quand vous êtes arrivé en
france vous avez 15 ans comment vous est
venu cet apprentissage par exemple du
saxophone ou d'autres instruments
comment comment vous avez commencé ce
métier j'ai commencé par l'harmonie
cahors à la maison d'abord en afrique et
puis fabriquer des pipots comme tout
avec des bambous dont ça veut dire que
j'ai soufflé quelques pas puis alan
shearer arrivé à celle d'alain dans la
sarthe là vous allez créer un festival
walaja festival ce sera d'ailleurs c'est
un des savates la sixième édition
pendant que j'y suis en profite mais
attend 4
disons que j'ai eu donc j'ai toujours
aimé la musique c'est vrai et à la
maison et avait une arme oignons c'est
aussi étrange que sa mère d'un harmonium
chez mon oncle quoi donc j'ai toujours
aimé les noirs et les blancs quoi en mai
2006 il était déjà la maison sans que je
sache elle attend l'arrivée la fête
chacun les enfants qui aiment la musique
j'ai profité du fait qu'il y avait deux
professeurs de musique pour apprendre le
piano et puis dans une colonie de
vacances vers 1953
saint-hilaire-du-harcouët à côté de
granville
j'avais un copain qui avait un saxo et
qui pourraient plus enjoué pour de santé
dit m quand une casse les pieds que les
matins à partager son piano je plaisante
et cerise à
gc mais je continue des cm écoutez vous
essayé beaucoup de talent on va vous
entendre au festival chorus avec ray
lema cette complicité les très anciennes
avec le zaïrois réelle elle est très
ancien figurez vous que j'ai rencontré
un lama la première fois 974 au combat
du siècle dans le coma du siec mohamed
ali foreman à kinshasa
à l'époque je venais de faire soul
makossa qui était très fort et
j'habitais les états unis et on était
parti avec les jays bradley fania all
star pour aller jouer pendant ce combat
de boxe dans le premier qu'on organisait
à la fiq à l'époque de mobutu et donc
j'ai rencontré les mal acquis qu'on
mangeait l'été puis les plus jeunes
comment d'ailleurs il commençait à être
connu et il m'a été présenté par un ami
un belge qui est décédé de nabeul noah
kersaint un très grand bassiste de jazz
ici dans les années 50 et vous avez tout
de suite plaisir le plaisir et puis
quelques années après beaucoup d'années
à penser retrouver en france qu'elle
avait mon insu télévision lahesalu
manuge et l'invitait l'a fait des choses
par disque interposés puis l'année
dernière je vais vite elle le café de la
danse je l'invité à paris ça a plus ça
nous a plus a plu aux gens à partir de
là on a fait le festival de nantes on a
fait pas mal de choses qu'on a décidé
après tout ya souvent herbie hancock et
wayne shorter qui font les choses
ensemble nos cousins américains nous
africains c'est plutôt d'habitude des
chanteurs qui sont à la nounou son
instrument this on a décidé de faire en
toutes ensemble et de jouer vous qui
avez été pionnier quelque part de la
musique africaine en france comment vous
voyez cette explosion aujourd'hui cette
grande mode de la musique africaine de
l'afrikaans en belgique on tacos harry
parce qu'au départ on aurait pris pour
un illuminé ou l utopie quoi savait pas
comment ce là toujours tort d'avoir
raison trop tôt on vous disait que ça
marchera jamais à genève il fallait que
tu t'appelles jackson ou quelque chose
comme ça dit ben moussa sow trop typique
toi et puis maintenant du bambou ray
lema filles on se souvient du fameux
t-il sable comme à sa cause là combien
de millions de disques vendus ni les
montois de ma part et puis avec un
michael jackson qui vous avez copié et
un procès maintenant contre jennifer qui
vous copie aussi la coquine à l'heure
actuelle au second trail m'écouter en
tout cas nous on viendra vous voir au
festival chorus sera le 22 mars que vous
jouerez avec ray lema merci d'être venu
nous voir bien sûr merci à vous c'est la
femme cette édition merci de là